hey guys hey guys hey guys hairy guys
Ryan right here Dan cyber here we're
gonna check out the Mass Effect
Andromeda III 2015 let's do this I'm so
excited
[Music]
oh yeah the trailer
Oh
[Music]
an old cowboy was driving out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
no I have questions I'm so many
questions like what okay all right
that's the fact nerds nerd out for me
with him in one he made a jump without a
mastery leg which we know those spoilers
minimal spoilers in a relay in order to
jump into light speed in that universe
okay
that's gone that's number one number two
the Makos back and the third one was a
new galaxy because in the first game
you're you don't leave your galaxy
because there's too much space between
you and the next Galaxy and now you're
going to another galaxy and I'm kind of
like big man it's been to be a madman I
have a question
yes you normally see the characters face
right yeah but you sometimes do right
yeah because I saw the fallout for a
gameplay trailer yeah and they really
let you just choose any [ __ ] feature
you could change the race yeah it's
amazing to be able to choose your own
race and all these other things do you
think that they might allow that in this
one they most definitely do they do for
the first three games you can change
your face and you could change your race
this time to possibly I doubt it because
that looked human it wouldn't make sense
for the I mean like ethnicity what yeah
I mean if you want I want to be a black
guy
of course you do I want to be a black
guys there won't be a black cowboy yeah
do you wanna be a sheriff yeah the ghost
riders in the sky my friend yeah worked
in blazing Saddles I'm so about this
yeah I want to see more gameplay I want
to see gameplay though that's the kind
of thing where it's like I mean have
they really amped it up or something I
have to see the I mean Mass Effect's
pretty cool game yeah well the one thing
that's really really freaking cool about
this is like just from that small little
bit song go through all those different
uh like environments right one critique
that I had about the original Mass
Effect is that sometimes the landscapes
kind of was like a generic palette swap
especially with the first game but like
in the later games it was
little buried but those were like so
radically different from each other and
they had such a great feel about each
area of super-stoked of what I could see
myself ejaculate into this game you what
I'd let you I would I would play the
game and let you just go ahead and do
what you got to do if you knew the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you take a dance gaming channel
that cyber channel you false on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine where if we
get enough followers we get piranhas
chloasma be able or more product place
or should I say money Cory den ham harm
my you name is Cory den Hannah I like a
shadow cuz I played Nintendo games yeah
and this really helped me get started
and not be a scrub thanks for listening
what was that mean I don't know but I
know he has a channel Cory listen um dan
is already gonna be conquering the
gaming side so there's no need for you
to do anything on YouTube you are at
this point useless you know you don't
belong in this world with us there's
it's oversaturated at this point
especially if you step in so you know
what Matt just reconsider it maybe
become a nurse or something follow your
dreams
yeah like go to medical school do what
your parents want you to do okay it's
something doing okay man good luck on
your gaming channel I hope I wish you
the best
yeah and I also hope for the worst I
hope before your continued health and
motivation to continue forward in this
game of life mm-hmm I hope you develop
hepatitis B